[Música]
seguimos con directo américa y hablamos
de economía con jorge hurtado jorge no
lo habíamos olvidado sino que como lo
dijimos al principio del programa
estamos dedicando directo américa a esta
cumbre con 26 en glasgow escocia pero
vamos a entonces hablar de la economía
de eeuu en europea porque finalmente
lograron un importante acuerdo atrás en
la cumbre del g 20 que terminó
justamente ayer previo a esta con 26 así
raúl para lo más importante que ese
acuerdo terminar con esta guerra
de aranceles que tenía la unión europea
y eeuu específicamente con el acero y el
aluminio que había iniciado con la
administración de donald trump en 2018
el entonces presidente trump impuso los
aranceles a la serie del aluminio
europeos argumentando que esos productos
amenazaban la seguridad nacional los
europeos y otros aliados respondieron
aplicando aranceles sobre motocicletas
whisky mantequilla de maní y otros
productos de estadounidenses aunque el
acuerdo mantiene los aranceles del 25
del 10 por ciento sobre el acero y el
aluminio permitirá que una cantidad
indefinida de esos productos procedentes
de la unión europea no sea gravado con
esas tarifas la unión europea retirará
las medidas de represalia y ambas y
renunciaron a las disputas legales la
agencia reuter asegura que el monto raúl
libre de aranceles de 33 millones de
toneladas anuales a partir de ahora el
acero que ingrese a los eeuu a través de
europa deberá haber sido producido
totalmente en europa una norma conocida
como fundido y vertido y esto dijo
ursula von der leyen que es presidenta
de la comisión europea
señor presidente usted y yo hemos
acordado hoy suspender los aranceles
sobre el acero y el aluminio y empezar a
trabajar en el nuevo acuerdo global de
acero sostenible y esto marca un hito en
la renovada asociación entre la unión
europea y los estados unidos y ese es
nuestro primer paso en nuestros
esfuerzos para lograr la
descarbonización de la producción y el
comercio mundial de la serie bond y 6a
action and trade porque como también lo
adelantábamos culmina el encuentro al
grupo del g20 le pregunto cuáles fueron
entonces los principales acuerdos en
materia económica raúl los dirigentes de
las 20 mayores economías del mundo
pactaron un acuerdo que calificaron de
histórico tras apoyar una reforma fiscal
internacional acordada por sus ministros
de economía se trata reunión nuevo marco
fiscal que incluye la creación de un
impuesto mínimo global del 15 por ciento
para los mayores multinacionales este
acuerdo también busca eliminar los
países paraísos fiscales y entraría en
vigencia en 2023 el impuesto dirigido a
multinacionales que facturan al menos
750 millones de euros en esa lista
ingresa empresas como google a por tu
favorita facebook y amazon en términos
de recaudación el impuesto busca
recaudar 150 mil millones de dólares al
año y otro de los pilares del impuesto
es proteger los derechos tributarios en
los países donde las multinacionales
operan y obtienen beneficios y no
solamente donde tienen su residencia
fiscal esto aplica para amazon por
ejemplo que podrá tener su residencia
fiscal en un país pero espera en muchos
del mundo jorgensen os agota el tiempo
por eso pues tenemos que ir de una vez a
los indicadores económicos le preguntó
entonces cómo están las bolsas mundiales
bueno reclamos en asia el índice nikkei
de la bolsa de tokio cerró con una
fuerte subida del 2,6 por ciento tras la
victoria de la coalición gobernante en
las elecciones generales celebradas en
japón en europa las bolsas alcanzaron
máximos históricos gracias a los
informes de beneficios mientras que un
aumento de las acciones bancarias animó
a los mercados de la zona euro
rápidamente volando cifra el día una
investigación del financial time dice
que snapshot facebook twitter y youtube
perdieron alrededor de 9 mil 850
millones de dólares en ingresos tras los
cambios de apple en sus políticas de
privacidad y volando en avión nos vamos
a parís directamente vámonos
[Música]